hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today we're
diving right back
into the exciting chaos of the boku no
hero manga
if you thought that after that crazy
twist at the end of chapter 306 we were
going to get a chapter that is a bit
more chill
you were wrong a new darker and more
badass izukumidoriya just challenged one
of the strongest villains in japan
to an epic rematch and things are only
getting more intense
as the hero society continues to unravel
so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero videos
on this channel and you want to support
the channel for free
just leave a like and a comment for the
youtube algorithm it really helps a lot
and if you are new to anime outpro or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications the only way to make
sure that you're not gonna miss a ton of
our videos
is to subscribe hit that bell and select
the option that says
all you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram
at anime uproar finally this video will
of course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have
been warned now after that crazy reveal
that deku is leaving the ua
i was thinking that we might not see
deku for a few chapters
i thought that the next few chapters
would focus on other characters
and we would then get to see deku making
a big comeback at a crucial moment
sometime down the line but deku made his
epic return
in the very next chapter as he first
saved the hero student
and then he set up a rematch with one of
the strongest villains in japan
that villain is of course muscular who
recently broke out of tartarus prison
and just like muscular's personality
this chapter had
zero chill and i loved it we start off
inside an urban neighborhood that has
been completely devastated by recent
villain and criminal activity
apparently one of the skps from tartarus
has been spotted
in this district so the entire area was
evacuated
some citizens are still inside this area
so two ketsubutsu hero students have
been dispatched to locate these missing
people
and get them to safety the two hero
students in question are characters
we've met before
during the provisional hero license
exams their names are
shindo and tatami eventually the two of
them are able to locate
the missing civilians who are holed up
together inside a building
shindo and tatami try to convince these
people to follow them to the shelter
but they refuse these people are not
just helpless civilians who are hiding
inside a building
they made the conscious decision not to
evacuate because after everything that
happened
they simply don't trust the heroes to
protect them these citizens feel that
they would be more
vulnerable inside the shelter so they
decided to band together
and make some sort of makeshift
vigilante militia
this group has already managed to take
down some of the criminals who tried
looting their neighborhoods in the past
so they're confident that they can also
protect their hometown against the
villains
shindo tries to explain that taking down
a few looters
is not the same as taking down an skp
from tartarus
but the citizens refused to listen and
the fact that the heroes
sent a couple of kids to protect these
people instead of full-fledged pro
heroes
only underscores the fact that the
heroes are weak and cannot be
trusted i mean the citizens do have a
point here after everything that
happened all the death
and chaos and destruction it's hard to
believe that the heroes know what
they're doing
and the fact that they're sending high
school students into these dangerous
areas
only shows that the heroes are getting
desperate these particular citizens are
more confident in their own collective
abilities than they are in the abilities
of a couple of high school students
so they choose to stand their ground and
shindo and tatami are forced to leave
the building
but then suddenly shindo and tatami get
a phone call that warns them to leave
the
area immediately a major villain is
heading their way
and clearly this villain is extremely
powerful because the two students were
not told to fight him
no they were told to run away as soon as
possible that villain turns out to be a
major threat and one of the main skps
from
tartarus muscular muscular begins
wreaking havoc around the neighborhood
and annihilating entire buildings with
his overpowered muscle
augmentation quirk muscular is as crazy
and destructive as ever
and he is itching for a fight shindo
bravely decides to stay and fight
against muscular
in order to buy some time while tatami
calls for backup and tries one more time
to evacuate those civilians from the
building
at first the civilians refuse again but
then they see what's going on outside
and it isn't pretty
shindo is fighting for his life against
the absolute monster
that is muscular shindo tries to use his
earthquake-inducing vibrate quirk to
break through muscular's many layers of
muscle
fibers he even uses an attack that he
wouldn't normally use because it can
seriously
injure or even kill an opponent
unfortunately for shindo
muscular is completely out of his league
muscular just adds even more layers to
his muscle fibers
and this negates the effects of shindo's
attack
just as it appears that muscular is
about to straight up murder shindo
someone smashes muscular from behind and
sends him flying
as muscular gets up and turns he sees
none other than our boy
deku in his full hero costume mask
included standing over him and holding a
seriously injured shindo
in his arms deku was able to find
muscular's exact location thanks to
danger sense
and that is how he was able to make it
in time to save shindo
muscular seems to recognize deku's voice
and his face
lights up with excitement as he realizes
that he now has an opportunity to get
revenge on the very person who sent him
to prison
and that is how this intense chapter
ends wow what a great chapter i really
liked that first half with the citizens
who refused to evacuate
because it's showing us to what extent
confidence in the heroes has eroded
the hero society is in such chaos that
entire districts have been evacuated
because of the villain threats
and then you have large groups of people
who are banding together to form
vigilante militias to protect themselves
because they do not trust the heroes
on top of that shindo almost died in
this chapter we have to appreciate the
gravity of that fact
if deku didn't show up in that exact
moment shindo would literally be
dead and yet it was the heroes who sent
him a high school student
into this dangerous situation the heroes
are obviously
short on manpower and they are
absolutely desperate
that is the only explanation for the
fact that they sent high school students
into an area where a major and
incredibly dangerous villain was spotted
in the future other hero students may
not be as lucky as shindo was
in this chapter and if this chaos
continues and if the heroes
keep relying on heroes students to fight
on the front lines
we may end up seeing some hero students
dying this policy of actually sending
high school students into these
dangerous situations
is such a massive shift as far as the
rules of the hero society go
and this really drives home just how
much things have changed since the
beginning of the story
before the events of the war arc sending
high school students into such dangerous
situations would have been
unimaginable but things have changed
drastically
and they may never be the same again
personally
i'm a little surprised that muscular is
just running around on his own
since i would have expected all for one
to recruit him into his personal villain
army since muscular is incredibly strong
and since he was affiliated with the
league of villains before
my guess was that he was going to serve
some sort of higher purpose
for all for one but who knows maybe
muscular's job was to bait deku and the
other big heroes to come out of hiding
and all for one may be watching all of
this
from behind the scenes and getting ready
to strike
either way though whether this is
muscular just being his crazy self or
whether this is part of a larger plan
i am very excited to see a rematch
between muscular
and deku this is going to be crazy
especially with deku's new powers and
his new
badass persona let me know what you guys
think how
awesome is vigilante deku do you think
that he will take
muscular out or is this going to become
a more complicated battle
like for example will other villains and
heroes
end up joining this fight also do you
think that deku
already has access to the quirks of the
second and third one for all user
and is he about to use them against
muscular
leave your feedback down in the comments
below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more pocono hero content right
here on the channel don't forget to
leave that like
it really helps a lot and if you're new
to anime pro or maybe you just haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans including ingrata
acquired respect pate heffa liam
thompson
algertol dr cortman dustin scarlett
emperor otaku spidey life
baked buddhist tungsten tarcus and yuno
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazatsky cricket xp rathune
deora
very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokamian water joanne garcia
the red-haired raven ted no ted
isparky65
fatboy games deadly saint and soul race
slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you